today's video is brought to you by
manscape comm it's the only brand that's
dedicated to helping you keep your
little nuts clean Shh
smooth they have the perfect tools for
your family jewels all right so why I'm
a big supporter of this I used to use
the hair clippers I use on my hair so
you're like baby well I get my hair cut
somewhere else now but I have leftover
clippers and they're not made for bat
wings so sometimes you're going to town
you're trying to shave them
you got random like skin folds that get
caught up in it and then it hurts and
you're like ah and you're bleeding all
over the place I've been there and then
later you take a shower and then it
stings like a mofo this thing I was
reading about it has like Nick say for a
safe Nick let's see it really great
technology skin safe technology so this
is perfect for your nuts and probably if
we have an actual pet bat
you could probably shave the bat to look
its it lights up oh that helps out too
so you could see in your Choudary a-- so
if you want to shave in the dark you
still can
yep so this is their new new which I've
been waiting for if actually had a
lawnmower 2.0 this is a lot more at 3.0
and it's the new new of the smoothest of
the shave wrist it's waterproof and
cordless so you could do it like on the
go so you could be running a marathon
while you're shaving your nuts or you
could be showering and saving your nuts
I prefer the shower or the marathon so
if you want the lawnmower 3.0 but you
also want a good deal check out the
package kit it comes with all kinds of
stuff got soft boxers they got some
Cullum there he also got hair and body
wash with active pH control and they
also got ball toner if you need your
balls to be toned so smooth and it came
with this box or than this bag that I
was like what that's not bad but it's
just a manscape man that's a cool travel
bag actually yeah hmm so everything to
take care of you in the nether regions
if you use are called JK news for the
perfect package 3.0 Kent this is what
you get you get 20% off your
a replacement blade every three months
and two free gifts balls to the walls
maybe so once again if you want to get
20% off use the code JK news you can get
all this good stuff to shave the little
nuts with because I know my little nuts
are really clean and thank you to
manscape for sponsoring our video all
right and never too late news and this
was submitted by come back to Hawaii I
was a Hollywood come back to Hawaii yes
a bar owner abruptly closed his business
to pursue his dream of being a male
exotic dancer in Vegas yeah who closed
their business a bar owner abruptly wait
why didn't he just create his bar change
his bar into yeah it was a [ __ ]
Kentucky and nobody was common to
butt-fuck Kentucky to see him as a bar
dancer you have to go to Vegas if you
want to do so this sounds like like he's
running from something yeah how is this
his dream it's like what people do when
they're desperate that does sound like a
cousin oh [ __ ] board it up I don't know
I'll figure it out yeah we're close get
the [ __ ] out everybody right anyone go
no don't worry about your tabs
everything settled that's how you know
it was a cover yeah come on man y'all
exotic dancers oh yeah cuz it's like
yeah it's the same business like
drinking club nightclubs great that's
heavy you're stripping for dudes though
probably yeah imagine that everyone
close your eyes just imagine this dude
with the thong mm-hmm sparkly thong yeah
yeah he has a big dick yep
what color's the thumb color purple
where's this going I don't know what you
guys to picture it a bit in a sparkly
thumb all right
yeah is he hard yeah yeah he's hurt
well if he's hard that means his dick is
going past his underwear it's going
through yeah
now the cops are coming to arrest him
and I was going to go okay wait I see it
he's really hard and now he's going like
this at me money waving at me oh wait oh
yeah I see it yeah oh wow I have a lot
of money a lot of money a string would
you ever go to a gay club more yeah what
just know you wouldn't yes yeah
apparently cuz in here I'm a rich man
[Laughter]
okay if it's a birthday party people are
going there for a reason yeah yeah but I
don't see myself just like wow yeah
whatever it was like a group of friends
yeah right and you had a gay friend in
the group and they were like hey let's
go here they have great drinks sure okay
yeah great drinks great drinks yeah I'm
pretty I'm pretty open might not do
anything I would yes absolutely for
great drinks and because like I'm thick
as [ __ ] and I'm handsome I'm normal get
you know sometimes you got to take a
compliment we can get him guys yeah - a
gay club I have I have been yes I've
been to a it was a drag Club right where
men and women dress up and drag I was
dating this chick she was bisexual this
was a st. Louis and she was performing
there and I went there and I went with
two of my best friends as guidance girl
we were all just just hanging out and
watching our I heard gay clubs are
pretty aggressive to people and like
grabbing and just pulling you away yeah
I mean but that's that's no different
for what ladies go through like if you
have a big hey sing like if she walks
behind a guy's legs real quick it's like
marrying like I don't like that does
something to me was just another reason
why I don't like one of clubs but I
guess I would imagine they were
same thing I walk by I'm thick as [ __ ]
my grandma omelette Hey I'm not here for
that
I'm just for the good drinks to the gay
club and I got hit on by a chick who's
sick so she was gonna [ __ ] you me
she thought you're a lady I'm very
comfortable just no I'm not [ __ ] all
right we're gonna lead guys on like that
though we're gonna lead them all I'm too
drunk get the name like I had a good
time like me to grow have a good way
like my dick is on the [ __ ] tease I
don't know what we're talking about if a
man leaned in to kiss me huh I think I
was a freak out what would you do I
don't know it just I just counted man
you're gonna freak out it's just sweet
innocent kiss - those are kids just see
like facial hair and all that just
coming close to do what he's gonna do
another man's presence come in he's
clean shaven but he's still brough like
it's still like like dude that's
actually how I felt when I true gonna
get the girl it was like oh you're way
too soft and like you smell really good
it's so weird a little bit like Dawkins
you're right
they're really soft and I'm just like
okay you're turning everyone on in this
actually like this everybody like values
mr that was really fun yeah then smells
good supple supple lips Geo I'm in a
weird video in a weird video what will
you like visualize the dicks and [ __ ]
you're the one that had a bunch of
tomorrow's lesbian [ __ ] anyway very
suspect right now zip up that jacket be
safe story man we're like halfway
through the video I haven't even told
you the story so alright so a bar owner
from San Francisco he so he has this bar
named cozy car and this there was this
note left and on the door and I will
read it right now it's pretty long so
I'm going to try my best to just get
through it best 2020 has been a bizarre
year already for the cozy card the owner
has walked away from the bar to become
an exotic dancer I received this text
today I wanted to be a male exotic
dancer dancer since I was in diapers I'm
50 years old and think that the time is
now it may seem crazy to you but I
believe that it's never too late to
pursue your dreams
I've taken years of pole dancing lessons
my moves are incredible my routine is
magical when I see this thing a sign I
see my name in bright blue neon lights
with a purple outline and this name is
so bright and so sharp at the sign it
just blows up because the name is so
powerful boogie next quote it's it is it
says Sam Young Chippendales dancer and
then so that was the end of the text I'm
doing my best to convince him to allow
us to open the bar again he wants the
entire staff to fly to Vegas to see him
on stage before he even consider is
allowing us to open the bar again so
this is actually happening we will keep
you posted
cozy Carson is a bit was the thing third
dick please yeah Dirk Diggler he's
[ __ ] with everybody this is great so
there was another note or go ahead I
think he may be dead I think somebody
killed him and they wrote the note they
have it
like that guy is there to cover up who
says I'm 50 years old and this is the
time to do it and my pole dancing
classes have are amazing who impregnated
a woman I might have your back here
because if he's dead and you create that
alibi nobody's gonna fly to Vegas to see
their I would fly it I'm like I gotta
see Elliot I mean soon it would not fly
to Vegas I would vote it was very money
on the flight and the hotel is their
biggest war which I could be you
wouldn't go okay boom this scenario Pike
is not around oh well guess what we're
in the real world well this is actually
happening okay this is your bar you're
working at the cozy car you're not
making enough money to fly to Vegas we
are but I'm pretty popular Barton so
people were like oh man is closed so
anyway there was this other notice on
the door
and it says someone responded with the
notice no it's the same boy the same boy
so it says to our customers the cozy car
will be closed due to strange and
unforeseen circumstances the owner has
decided to pursue his dreams of male
exotic dancing and has moved to Las
Vegas we do not think he has the body
for it while we do not think he for it
attitude and dancing are beyond
comprehension and when he is stripping
he has certainly he has a certain Jenna
sequelae about him it's a gift for
reasons that make no sense he has turned
over control to the business oh I love
this dog he has turned control he has
turned over control to the business to
his dog
Dixie okay by the owners attorney that
Dixie is now CEO of the company we wish
this was a joke but it's not this is
actually had no [ __ ] time they said
this actually happened we
milisecond reality is stranger than
fiction and this is the perfect example
the manager of the cozy car has taken it
upon himself to rectify the situation
and get the bar back open he believes
he'll be able to get the bar running
again by January 9th 2020 this was
posted on January 5th look hang on a
second also the yep it's true the dog is
running for president
I mean what kind of dog is it yeah right
this is a head scratcher in a situation
that defies all logic the staff wishes
the owner of the best in his pursuit of
his dream
we are pissed that he left the dog in
control of the company cheers bro no I'm
not buying any of this one last one good
story let me tell you this
killers hilarious this has the date of
January 8th 2020 it says I feel so
insignificant I just returned from Las
Vegas I was at Sam's audition at
Chippendales I had tears in my eyes it
was beyond a show it was life-changing
my life will never be the same after
seeing his audition it was magic I still
have goosebumps I do not have the
vocabulary to describe the passion the
feeling the emotion that he was able to
provoke in my mind body and soul but I
will try because I feel that I owe you
at least that if Jesus came down from
heaven and spoke to me it would be less
impressive what I witnessed his dancing
had the state of being I'm in I'm so
here exemplified a supreme excellence
his moves cut like a razor he flowed
like river and fluff floated like a
butterfly he was Fred Astaire Gene Kelly
world peace was in the room with us that
night um he was actually better than
that as he left the stage he said I'm a
star I'm a star I'm a star I'm a star
I'm a big bright shining star yeah
that's right after hearing those words I
cried uncontrollably because at that
moment I knew I had witnessed an event
greater than the parting of the Red Sea
after his audition he never saw Boogie
Nights after his audition we spoke at
length about the bar I was able to
convince him to allow me
the bar open so we will be resuming
business starting Thursday January 9th
fake advertisement okay first off I
retract my form of statements he's not
dead no electricity got cut off
electricity got cut off for weekly had
to get the money that you had the buy
time he came up with this now will this
bigger picture think bigger picture okay
is he still in Vegas dancing gambling
well I guarantee he's not hey never wait
you should be a poet know the
[ __ ] can write his ass on Ian
quote movies quote movies out of that
suit that's all you can write the next
Hogwarts Hogwarts special or some [ __ ]
next Harry Potter there yeah because
that mean Jenna's like wah and a [ __ ]
explanation I can't even talk about that
means I say it all the time so like a
certain finesse and flyness or yeah it's
a tunnel
unspeakable talent thing it's like that
unspeakable it all comes together
perfectly Dena first time I heard it use
was regime or live a single fancy watch
to tans I what about that talent listen
in Chinese it's nice part it just
doesn't roll like Gina sake watching
woman's nipples as you say hi Oh can't I
Timothy Nadal they're not quite the same
I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]